here is the prime minister make a
statement on her future ever since I
first stepped through the door behind me
as Prime Minister I have striven to make
the United Kingdom a country that works
not just for a privileged few
but for everyone and to honor the result
of the EU referendum back in 2016 we
gave the British people a choice against
all predictions the British people voted
to leave the European Union I feel as
certain today as I did three years ago
that in a democracy if you give people a
choice you have a duty to implement what
they decide I have done my best to do
that I negotiated the terms of our exit
and a new relationship with our closest
neighbors that protects jobs our
security and our union I have done
everything I can to convince MPs to back
that deal sadly I have not been able to
do so I tried three times I believe it
was right to persevere even when the
odds against success seemed high but it
is now clear to me that is it it is in
the best interests of the country for a
new prime minister to lead that effort
so I am today announcing that I will
resign as leader of the conservative and
unionist party on Friday the 7th of June
so that a successor can be chosen I've
agreed with the party chairman and with
the chairman of the 1922 committee that
the process for electing a new leader
should begin in the following week I
have kept her Majesty the Queen fully
informed of my intentions and I will
continue to serve as her prime minister
until the process has concluded it is
and will always remain a matter of deep
regret to me that I have not been able
to deliver brexit it will be for my
successor to seek a way forward that
honors the result of the referendum to
succeed he or she will have to find
consensus
in Parliament where I have not such a
consensus can only be reached if those
on all sides of the debate are willing
to compromise for many years the great
humanitarians and Nicholas Winton who
saved the lives of hundreds of children
by arranging their evacuation from Nazi
occupied Czechoslovakia through the
Kindertransport was my constituent in
Maidenhead at another time of political
controversy a few years before his death
he took me to one side at a local event
and gave me a piece of advice
he said never forget that compromise is
not a dirty word life depends on
compromise he was right as we strive to
find the compromises we need in our
politics whether to deliver brexit or to
restore devolved government in northern
ireland we must remember what brought us
here because the referendum was not just
a call to leave the EU but for profound
change in our country a call to make the
United Kingdom a country that truly
works for everyone